[Music]
mr. president I'm delighted to welcome
you and mrs. Trump to Buckingham Palace
this evening just 12 months after our
first meeting at Windsor visits by
American presidents always remind us of
the clothes and long-standing friendship
between the United Kingdom and the
United States and I'm so glad that we
have another opportunity to demonstrate
the immense importance that both our
countries attach to our relationship in
the coming days you will see some of our
most treasured historical buildings
speak to the business leaders whose
expertise and innovation drive our
economies and meet members of our armed
services past and present you will also
travel to Portsmouth and Normandy to
commemorate the 75th anniversary of
d-day on that day and on many occasions
since the armed forces of both our
countries fought side-by-side to defend
our cherished values of Liberty and
democracy mr. president in your State of
the Union address this year you paid
tribute to some of the American heroes
who risk their lives and we owe an
immeasurable in a miserable debt to the
British American and allied soldiers who
began the liberation of Europe on the
6th of June 1944 I paid my first state
visit to your country but the invitation
of President Eisenhower as supreme
Allied commander he had ultimate
responsibility for the execution of the
Normandy landings
in his headquarters and st. James's
square not far from Buckingham Palace
British and American officers worked
closely together to plan the freedom of
a continent and it would be no
exaggeration to say that millions of
lives depended on their common endeavor
as we face the new challenges of the
21st century the anniversary of d-day
reminds us of all that our countries
have achieved together after the shared
sacrifices of the Second World War
Britain and the United States worked
with other allies to build an assembly
of international institutions to ensure
that the horrors of conflict would never
be repeated while the world has changed
we are forever mindful of the original
purpose of these structures nations
working together to safeguard a hard-won
peace of course it is not only our
security which unites us but our strong
cultural links and shared heritage every
year there are almost 4 million visits
by Americans to the United Kingdom with
a great number claiming British descent
and with your own Scottish ancestry mr.
president you too have a particular
connection to this country we are also
bound by the strength and breadth of our
economic ties as the largest investors
in each other's economies British
companies in the United States employ
over 1 million Americans and the same is
true vice versa mr. president as we look
to the future I'm confident that our
common values and shared interests
we'll continue to unite us tonight we
celebrate an alliance that has helped to
ensure the safety and prosperity of both
our peoples for decades and which I
believe will endure for many years to
come ladies and gentlemen I invite you
all to rise and drink a toast to
president and mrs. Trump to the
continued friendship between our two
nations and to the health prosperity and
happiness of the people of the United
States
[Music]
[Applause]
your majesty Melania and I are
profoundly honored to be your guest for
this historic state visit thank you for
your warm welcome for this beautiful
weather your gracious hospitality and
your Majesty's nearly seven decades of
treasured friendship with the United
States of America this week we
commemorate a mighty endeavor of
righteous Nations and one of the
greatest undertakings in all of history
75 years ago more than 150,000 Allied
troops were preparing on this island to
parachute into France stormed the
beaches of Normandy and win back our
civilization as Her Majesty remembers
the British people had hoped and prayed
and fought for this day for nearly five
years when Britain stood alone during
the Blitz of 1940 and 1941 the Nazi war
machine dropped thousands of bombs on
this country and right on this
magnificent City Buckingham Palace alone
was bombed on 16 separate occasions in
that dark hour the people of this nation
showed the world what it means to be
British they cleared records from the
streets displayed the Union Jack from
their shattered homes and kept fighting
on to victory they only wanted victory
the courage of the United Kingdom's sons
and daughters ensured that your destiny
would always remain in your own hands
through it all the royal family was the
resolute face of the Commonwealth's
unwavering solidarity in April 1945
newspapers featured a picture
of the queen-mother visiting the woman's
branch of the army watching a young
woman repair a military truck engine
that young mechanic was the future queen
a great great woman Her Majesty inspired
her compatriots in that fight to support
the troops defend her homeland and
defeat the enemy at all cost we also pay
tribute to Prince Philip's distinguished
and valiant service in the Royal Navy
during the Second World War on d-day the
Queen's beloved father King George the
sixth delivered a stirring national
address that day he said after nearly
five years of toil and sufferin we must
renew that crusading impulse on which we
entered the war and met its darkest hour
our fight is against evil and for a
world in which goodness and honor may be
the foundation of the life of men in
every land this evening we thank God for
the brave sons of the United Kingdom and
the United States who defeated the Nazis
and the Nazi regime and liberated
millions from tyranny the bond between
our nation's was forever sealed in that
great crusade as we honor our shared
victory in heritage we affirm the common
values that will unite us long into the
future freedom sovereignty
self-determination the rule of law and
reference for the rights given to us by
Almighty God from the Second World War
to today Her Majesty has stood as a
constant symbol of these priceless
traditions she has embodied the
spirit of dignity duty and patriotism
that beats proudly in every British part
on behalf of all Americans I offer a
toast to the eternal friendship of our
people the vitality of our nation's and
to the long cherished and truly
remarkable reign of Her Majesty the
Queen
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]